graph the solution set for this system
it's a system of inequalities we have Y
is greater than X minus 8 and Y is less
than 5 minus X so let's graph the
solution set for each of these
inequalities and then essentially where
they overlap is the solution set for the
system the set of numbers that's or the
set of coordinates that satisfy both so
let me draw a coordinate axes here so
that is my x-axis and then I have my
y-axis and that is my y-axis and now let
me draw the boundary line the boundary
for this first inequality so the
boundary line is going to look like Y is
equal to X minus 8 but it's not going to
include it because it's only greater
than X minus 8 but let's just graph X
minus 8 so we're the y intercept here is
negative 8 when x is 0 Y is going to be
negative 8 so let's go
negative 1 negative 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so
that is negative 8 so the point 0
negative 8 is on the line and then it
has a slope of 1 this is a you don't see
it right there but I could write it as 1
X so the slope here is going to be 1 I
could just draw a line that goes
straight up or you could even say that
it'll intersect if Y is equal to 0 if Y
we're equal to 0 X would be equal to 8
so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and so this is X is
equal to 8 if it has a slope of 1 for
every time you move to the right 1
you're going to move up 1 so the line is
going to look something like this and
actually let me draw it not drawn as a
solid line if I did it as a solid line
that would actually be this equation
right here but we we're not going to
include that line we care about the Y
values that are greater than that line
so what we want to do is do a dotted
line to show that that's just the
boundary that we're not including that
we're not including that in our solution
set let me do this in a new color so
this would be this will be the color for
that line or for that inequality I
should say so that is the boundary line
and this says y is greater than X minus
8 so you pick an X and then X minus 8
would get us on the boundary line and
then Y is greater than that so it's all
the Y value
is above above the line for any given X
so it'll be this it'll be this region
above the line right over here and if
that confuses you I mean in general I
like to distinct oh great er then it's
going to be above the line if it's less
than it's going to be below a line but
if you want to make sure you can just
test on either side of this line so you
could try the point zero zero which
should be in our solution set and if you
say zero is greater than zero minus
eight or zero is greater than negative
eight that works so this definitely
should be part of the solutions and then
you could try something out here like
like ten comma zero and see that it
doesn't work because you would have 10
minus 8 which would be 2 which and then
you would have zero and zero is not
greater than two so when you test
something out here you also see that it
won't work but in general I like to just
say hey look this is the boundary line
and we're greater than the boundary line
for any given X now let's do this one
over here let's do this one the boundary
line for it is going to be y is equal to
five minus x so the boundary line is y
is equal to 5 minus x so once again if x
is equal to zero Y is 5 so 1 2 3 4 5 and
then it has a slope of negative 1 we
could write this as Y is equal to
negative 1 X plus 5 that's a little bit
more traditional so once again y
intercept at 5 it has a slope of
negative 1 or another way to think about
it when y is 0 when y is 0 X will be
equal to 5 so 1 2 3 4 5 so every time we
move to the right one we go down 1 so we
have a negative 1 slope so it will look
it will look like this and once again I
want to do a dotted line I want to do a
dotted line because we are so that is
our dotted line and I'm doing a dotted
line because it says y is less than 5
minus X if it was look if it was y is
equal to 5 minus X I would have included
the line if it was y is less than or
equal to 5 minus X I also would have
made this line solid but it's only less
than so for any x value for any x value
this is what 5 minus x 5 minus X will
sit on that boundary line but we care
about the Y values that are less than
that so we want all everything that is
everything that is ball
hello the line and once again you can
test on either side of the line zero
zero should work for this second
inequality right here zero is indeed
less than five minus is zero zero is
less than five and you could try
something like zero ten and see that it
doesn't work because if you had ten is
less than five minus zero that doesn't
work so it is everything below the line
like that and like we said the solution
set for this system the solution set for
the system are all of the X's and Y's
all of the coordinates that satisfy both
of them so all the shaded in purple
satisfies the second inequality all the
shaded in green satisfies the first
inequality so the stuff that satisfies
both of them is their overlap so it's
all of this region in blue hopefully
this isn't making it too messy
all of this region in blue where the two
overlap below the magenta dotted line on
the left-hand side and above the green
magenta line that's only where they
overlap so it's only this region only
this region over here and you're not
including the boundary lines